begraben von einer 900 meter dicke
eisschicht ewiger dunkelheit und
eiskalte temperaturen und genau in
dieser todeszone wurde jetzt mit hilfe
einer unterwasserkamera eine wirklich
unglaubliche entdeckung gemacht leben
bislang nicht identifizierte lebewesen
wie kann das sein
und was bedeutet das für unsere suche
nach außerirdischem leben klicks zum
science in future hier gibt es drei mal
pro woche spannendes heinz videos
abonniert den kanal und aktiviert die
glocke nur dann verpasst der nächsten
los geht's herzlich willkommen und denkt
an den podcast eine für unterwegs nur
zum hören hier unter mir ist der blick
es handelt sich um einen echten
zufallsfund aber der ist tatsächlich
umso spektakulärer ein internationales
forschungsteam hat nämlich den
meeresboden unter dem schelfeis der
antarktis genauer ins visier genommen
mit hilfe von einem spezial systemen
gelang es den wissenschaftlerinnen und
wissenschaftlern das eis zu durchbohren
eine echte herausforderung denn das eis
hat an dieser stelle eine dicke von
achtung 900 metern also fast ein
kilometer was die fachleute bei dieser
bohrung entdeckten hatten sie nicht für
möglichkeiten denn bei ihrer bohrung
stießen sie anders als erwartet nicht
aufweichen meeresboden stattdessen
trafen sie fällt schnell stand der
entschluss fest eine kamera auf den
boden zu lassen um sich diese todeszone
genauer anzuschauen und so wartet in die
nächste überraschung auf das
forschungsteam leben und zwar ganz
konkret mindestens zwei verschiedene
organismen arten die einen etwa so groß
wie eine münze und die anderen mit stil
förmigen körpern die mit einer kugel
enden teilweise bis zu zehn zentimeter
lang eine echte überraschung und eine
premiere noch dazu das forschungsteam
schreibt dazu das ist die erste
aufzeichnung einer sehr vielen
lebensgemeinschaft auf hartem grund
unter einem schelfeis heißt also im
klartext noch nie zuvor wurde eine
organismen gruppe unter dem schelfeis
gefunden die dort am untergrund
festgewachsen ist denn das heißt sie
ziehen denn diese organismen können nach
meinung der fachleute dort unter dem
schiff als gar nicht existieren bislang
gegen forschungsteams davon aus dass
diese organismen nämlich darauf
angewiesen sind dass die im wasser steht
um ihnen nahrung verschafft genügend
organische partikel also von der
wasseroberfläche zu ihnen transportiert
werden doch das ist in einer solchen
großen entfernung vom ausland wohl nicht
möglich und die bohrung des
forschungsteams tanten ganze 260
kilometer vom rand des eispanzers
entfernt statt wie also kann das seien
und um welche lebensform handelt es sich
fest steht hier sind die bedingungen
wirklich alles andere als
lebensfreundlich es ist die ganze zeit
dunkel
es herrscht eine eisige kälte und das
leben hier unter dem eis der polarmeere
ist extrem hart dennoch wurden hier
bereits in der vergangenheit zumindest
mikroorganismen im wasser und im
sediment von antarktischen sehen
nachgewiesen sogar fische und krebse
konnten in der vergangenheit unter dem
schelfeis des polymers aufgespürt werden
dennoch wenn wir ehrlich sind wissen wir
menschen kaum etwas zu dieser welt unter
dem ewigen eis wie auch die
fachzeitschrift nature hat diese region
deswegen auch einmal als das größte
unerforschte ökosystem des planeten
genannt denn um in die entsprechenden
tiefen zu gelangen sind tagelange bohren
notwendig doch wissenschaftlerinnen
wissenschaftler weltweit sind sehr
interessiert daran mehr über diese
gebiet zu erfahren 2013 gelangen eine
erste bohrung eines sub glazialen sees
also zu einem see der sich unter einem
gletscher befindet dem sogenannten lake
willens die untersuchungen zeigten dass
sie reichlich mikrobiellen leben möglich
ist und das trotz der extremen
bedingungen dort unten anzeichen für
höheres leben fand sich damals aber
nicht
ein internationales forschungsteam hatte
vor zwei jahren eine weitere
herausforderung angenommen und es hat
sich gelohnt mehrere tage lang hatten
sich die fachleute mit hilfe eines
hochdruck und heißwasser bohrers durch
eine knapp 1100 meter dicke eisschicht
600 kilometer vom südpol entfernt
gearbeitet zu erreichen sind dann
endlich den antarktischen sozialen sehen
namens league moerser der eine fläche
von 160 quadratkilometern hat somit ist
er doppelt so groß wie manhattan und
nicht nur dass seine tiefe wird auf zehn
bis 15 meter geschätzt solche seen
entstehen wohl weil die erdkruste wärmer
ist als die eisdecke die darüber liegt
das gestein fungiert also als eine art
wärmequelle und sorgt dafür dass die
eisdecke von unten schmilzt die
forschenden nutzen also den gebohrten
schacht im eis um eine wasserprobe zu
entnehmen und tatsächlich
den eisigen gewässern des leg mercer
lauern unzählige organismen die
forschenden konnten also nicht nur
mikroben und kieselalgen aufspüren
sondern auch spuren von winzigen tieren
pilzen und pflanzen vor allem der fund
von krebstierchen und wer tiere in so
genannten tat die gerade überraschte das
forschungsteam auch wenn sie bereits
abgestorben haben gehen die fachleute
davon aus dass das überleben dieser
organismen unter dem eis der antarktis
möglich ist sie vermuten dass sich die
lebewesen von bakterien und sauerstoff
ernährt haben der wohl in ausreichendem
maß enthalten ist ausgeschlossen ist
ganz sicher nicht das auch noch die ein
oder andere unentdeckte spezies
aufgespürt wird die sich seit unzähligen
jahren unter der dicken eisschicht
verbot doch eben eine organismen gruppe
wurde bislang eben noch nie unter dem
schelfeis gefunden tiere die am
untergrund fest gewachsen sind und auf
die wasserströmung angewiesen sind dass
sie sich durch das filtrieren des
wassers an ihren gemeinsinn
beispielweise seepocken musste ich hin
kaltwasserkorallen einige borsten würmer
und viele schwämme und damit zurück zu
der aktuellen studie an der auch how
griffes vom british antarctic survey
beteiligt war er sagt dazu viele trierer
sind gängiger lehrmeinung nach auf
bereiche nahe der ice von begrenzt wo
ein direkter ein strom vom offenen meer
aus existiert doch die videoaufnahmen
enthüllen genau das was bislang als
unmöglich eingestuft wurde auf den
felsen der rund 800 meter unter dem eis
und mehrere hundert kilometer vom
offenen meer entfernt ist konnte eine
sehr viele also auf dem felsen fest
gewachsene lebensgemeinschaft aufgespürt
werden und zwar gleich mehrere
verschiedene sehr viele väter organismen
wie es in der aktuellen studie heißt mit
dabei waren unter anderem bullige müntz
große gebilde
die fachleute gehen davon aus dass es
sich hierbei um schwämme handelt doch
wie leben diese und wie ihr nähern sie
sich außerdem an staat ungestillte
schwämme und weitere bislang noch nicht
identifizierte subventionsfässer mit
stilen diese stil förmigen körper die in
einer kugel enden stellen die fachleute
für ein großes rätsel
die organismen sind teilweise bis zu
zehn zentimeter lang und sitzen mit
abgeflachten füßen grüppchenweise auf
den steinen weitere details waren auf
dem video aufnahmen leider nicht zu
erkennen somit ist bislang noch völlig
unklar welche organismen gruppe dieser
körper angehören die vermutung der
wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler
aber ist
das zumindest die schwämme fleisch
fressen sind fest steht ebenfalls diese
lebensgemeinschaft hat sich eine ganz
besondere lage ausgesucht die fachleute
konnten analysiert dass die strömungen
in diesem gebiet verhindern dass das
wasser vom offenen ozean bis zu diesem
ort strömt denn die strömung in diesem
gebiet ist zwar stark fließt aber in die
falsche richtung vom ozean aus erst
einmal unter dem eis um die bucht bevor
sie dann dem nun aufgespürt und felsen
dort ankommt heißt also im klartext die
neu entdeckten viele trierer sind weit
entfernt von jeglichen algen und
plankton resten die herab rieseln dazu
heißt es in der aktuellen studie
diese strömung bedeuten dass diese
lebensgemeinschaft zwischen 625 und 1500
kilometer vom nächsten meeresgebiet mit
photosynthese entfernt liegt diese
entdeckung erfordert ein umdenken darin
welche organismen und gemeinschaften
unter dem schelfeis vorkommen
möglicherweise fressen die exotischen
organismen aber auch die schwebstoffe
die von weit her transportiert wurden
zudem könnten sie sich auch auf
organische substanzen stürzen
die von der ice unterseite nahe der
grundlinie des schelfeises frei
schmelzen doch das sind bisher alles nur
vermutungen
denn zahlreiche fragen sind offen wie
kamen die organismen an diesen ort was
fressen sie wirklich und wie lange sind
sie schon dort handelt es sich um
dieselbe lebewesen die auch im offenen
meer leben und wie häufig sind solche
bewachsenen felsen handelt es sich
möglicherweise um ganze neue unbekannte
arten in der zukunft erhoffen sich die
fachleute antworten auf diese frage
möglicherweise könnte das alles durch
dna analysen geklärt werden eine sache
aber wird durch die aktuelle entdeckung
noch einmal deutlich gewesen kaum etwas
über die bereiche unter dem schelfeis
dazu schreibt das forschungsteam unser
gesamtes wissen über die mehr als 1,5
millionen quadratkilometer der sucht
glazialen chefs habitat stammt von
beobachtungen an zehn einzelnen
bohrlöchern
diese machen zusammen gerade einmal die
fläche eines tennisplatzes aus es ist
daher kein wunder dass wir immer wieder
unbekannte arten von sub schelfeis
gemeinschaften entdecken
um es noch einmal deutlich zu machen wir
wissen gerade einmal von einer fläche
die der größe eines tennisplatzes
entspricht doch ob wir die ökosysteme
unter dem eis jemals beschreiben könnten
das risiko ist hoch dass sie schon in
der nahen zukunft verschwunden sind denn
die globale erwärmung sorgt dafür dass
der eispanzer der antarktis an vielen
stellen aus
dennoch auch für unsere suche nach
außerirdischem leben könnten diese
erkenntnisse spannend sein denn diese
biosphäre kann man mit potenziellen
lebensraum tief im mars oder auf den
eisbedeckten monaten von saturn und
jupiter vergleichen neue ergebnisse
welches leben sich unter dem schelfeis
abspielt und vor allem die es möglich
wird könnte also auch spannende indizien
dafür liefern welche art von neben solch
exotische bedingungen beherbergen können
außerirdisches leben auf der erde
anklicken anschauen und abonnieren also
klicks und future diesen hammer kanal
nicht vergessen auf abo drückt mir dort
überall und ansonsten bis dann bleib
dran